here have drawn the most classic
parabola y is equal to x squared and
what I want to do is think about what
happens if I were to if or how can I go
about shifting this parabola and so
let's think about a couple of examples
so let's think about the graph of the
curve this is y is equal to x squared
let's think about what the curve of y
minus K is equal to x squared what would
this look like well right over here we
see when X is equal to 0 x squared is
equal to 0 that's the one this the CLO
curve so x squared is equal to Y or Y is
equal to x squared but for this one x
squared isn't equal to Y it's equal to Y
minus K so when x equals 0 and we square
it 0 squared doesn't get us to Y it gets
us to Y minus K so this is going to be K
less than Y or another way of thinking
about it this is 0 if it's K less than Y
y must be at K wherever K might be so y
must be at K right over there so at
least for this point it had the effect
of shifting up the Y the Y value by K
and that's actually true for any of
these values so let's think about X
being right over here for this yellow
curve you square this x value and you
get it there and it's clearly not drawn
the scale the way that I've done it
right over here but you square this x
value you get there but now for this
curve right over here x squared doesn't
cut it it only gets you to Y minus K so
K must be or Y must be K higher than
this so this is y minus K y must be K
higher than this so y must be right over
here so this curve is essentially this
blue curve shifted up by K shifted up so
making it Y minus K is equal x squared
shifted it up by K whatever value this
is shifted up by K this distance is a
constant is a constant K the vertical
distance between between these two
parabolas I'll try to draw it as cleanly
as cleanly as I can this vertical
distance is a constant K now let's think
about shifting in the horizontal
direction let's think about what happens
if I were to say Y is equal to not x
squared
but X minus H X minus H squared so let's
think about it this is the value you get
for y when you just square 0 you get Y
is equal to 0 how do we get y equals 0
over here
well this quantity right over here has
to be 0 so X minus H has to be 0 or X
has to be equal to H so let's say that H
is right over here so X has to be equal
to H so one way to think about it is
whatever value you are squaring here to
get your Y you now have to have an H
higher value to square that same thing
because you're going to subtract H from
it just to get to 0 X has to even just 2
square is 0 just to square 0 X has to
equal H here if you wanted to square one
X just have to be equal to 1 so if your
year let's just say for the sake of
argument that this is the value this is
X is equal to 1 and this is 1 squared
clearly not drawn to scale so that would
be 1 as well but now to square one we
don't have to just get it x equals 1 X
has to be H plus 1 it has to be one
higher than H it has to be H plus 1 to
get to that same point so you see the
net effect is that by instead of
squaring just X but squaring X minus H
we shifted the curve to the right so the
curve we do this in this purple color
the curve this magenta color will look
like this we shifted it we shifted it to
the right and we shifted it to the right
to the right by we shifted it to the
right by H now let's think of another
thought experiment let's imagine let's
imagine that let's think about the curve
Y is equal to negative x squared
well now whatever the value of x squared
is we're going to take the negative of
it so here no matter what X we took we
square it we got a positive value now
we're going to we're always going to get
a negative value once we multiply it
times a negative one so it's going to
look like this it's going to be a mirror
image of y equals x squared reflected
over the horizontal axis so it's going
to look something like that
so that's y is equal to negative x
squared
and now let's just imagine scaling it
even more what would Y what would y
equal y equal negative 2x squared well
now actually let me do two things so
what would Y equals 2x squared look like
so let's just the positive version so y
equals 2x squared well now as we square
things we're going to multiply them by
two so it's going to increase faster so
it's going to look something like this
it's going to be narrower and steeper so
it might look something like this and
once again I'm just giving you the idea
haven't really drawn this to scale so
this will this increasing it by a factor
will make it increase faster if we did y
equals negative 2x squared if we did y
equals negative 2x squared well then
it's going to get negative faster on
either side so it's going to look
something like this it's going to be the
mirror image of what I just drew so it's
going to be a narrower a narrower
parabola just like that and similarly
and I know that my diagram is getting
really messy right now but just remember
we started with y equals x squared which
is this curve right over here what
happens if we did y equals 1/2 x squared
so let's move I'm running out of colors
as well if we did y equals 1/2 x squared
well then the thing is going to increase
slower it's going to look the same but
it's going to open up wider it's going
to increase slower it's going to look
something something like this so this
hopefully gives you a sense of how we
can shift parabolas around so for
example so for example if I have if I
have and I'm going to do it I'm doing a
very rough drawing here to give you the
general idea of what we're talking about
so if this if this is y equals x squared
so that's the graph of y equals x
squared that's y is equal to x squared
the graph of y let me do this in a color
that I haven't used yet the graph of y
minus K is equal to a times X minus H
squared will look something like this
instead of the vertex being at zero zero
the
vertex or the lowest or I guess you
could say the minimum or the maximum
point the extreme point in the parabola
at this point right over here would be
the maximum point for a downward-opening
parabola a minimum point for an
upward-opening parabola that's going to
be shifted it's going to be shifted by H
to the right H to the right and K up K
up so its vertex it's going to be right
over here and it's going to be scaled by
a if a is greater than so if a is equal
to one it's going to look the same it's
going to have the same opening it's
going to have the same opening so that's
a equals one if a is greater than one
it's going to it's going to it's going
to be steeper like this if a is less
than 1 but greater than zero it's just
going to be wider opening like that if a
is actually if a is zero then it just
turns into a flat it turns into a flat
line and then if a is negative but less
than negative one it's kind of a broad
opening things like that or I should say
greater than negative one if it's
between zero and negative one it'll be a
broad opening thing like that at
negative one it'll look like a
reflection of our original curve and
then if it's if a is less than negative
one so it's even more negative than it's
going to be even a steeper a steeper
parabola that might look like that so
hopefully that gives you a good way of
how to shift and scale parabolas